yann moix donc ça s'appelle partout et
c'est édité chez chez grasset est-ce que
vous êtes prêts pour une interview
portrait sexuelle haye
si vous étiez une position la position
du tireur couché un accessoire ou femme
un tue l'amour un homme aphrodisiaques
deux femmes une musique pour faire
l'amour
je vous interdis un cri [ __ ] si vous
étiez une panne une panne de coeur si
vous étiez une perversion un concours de
[ __ ] un film porno podium un fantasme
un fantasme
attendez laissez moi réfléchir
je passe je sais pas si vous étiez
quelque chose qui fait mal
un fils king mike tyson
si vous étiez une boîte à partouze ma
chambre
si vous étiez une phrase à la con qu'on
dit avant l'amour tu as lu le dernier
livre de jacques attali que c'est une
phrase de la con qu'on dit après l'amour
surtout tu le répètes à personne si vous
étiez une tâche
moi si vous étiez un truc qui se fait à
plusieurs un livre de paul loup sulitzer
par 12
c'est grâce à la messieurs
m